hello freak [ __ ] but he beat Conor
McGregor in a way that you would expect
a real specialist to beat someone who's
just pretty good at it
he was masterful [ __ ] awesome to
watch and what Connor said afterwards
hilarious - I turned him into a Mexican
he fought like a Mexican because that's
what people love about Mexican fighters
that Mexican fighters are known for
coming straight at you like Mexican
fighters aren't dancers they're not
dancing around and you know doing the
Ollie shuffle
they're like Julio Cesar Chavez there's
moving forward you know they're like
Marco Antonio Barrera they're moving
forward Mexican boxers are like some of
the proudest most rugged warriors ever
that's how Floyd fought fought it really
did fight like a super technical
aggressive brawling styling tired Conor
out that beat his ass beautiful man
beautiful for boxing beautiful for for
the overall art of fighting because it
we need to see these things I think this
thing that we're all participating in
fans of MMA practitioners of MMA this
thing that we're all participating in is
trying to figure out what style is the
very best style for fighting period and
then we found along the way that it
varies it varies on the individual
styles make fights and then sometimes
one guy can beat another guy but that
guy can beat someone could beat him and
it gets real weird like MMA math is like
one of the squirrely is [ __ ]
predictors of like who's gonna win a
fight ever but we're finding out like
what what's [ __ ] real like when
you've got all the belief in yourself in
the world when you've got knockout power
when you really believe you could beat
the greatest boxer of all time what
happens oh you get [ __ ] up okay that's
good it's good to learn it's good to
learn it's good to learn that even
though he lands it if he lands a few
shots makes it a real interesting
contest good to learn that the best
specialist of all time is that for a
reason this isn't [ __ ] this is a
Floyd Mayweather he's 49 and now now
he's 50 you know I mean that's that's
good for combat sport it's good for
everybody
that's what's so stupid about this whole
boxing versus MMA feud it's so dumb it
gets everybody excited about fights and
this intercom
titian thing between an MMA fighter
coming over to boxing that's even more
fun because then it gets like everything
excited on both sides and I think it's
gotten a lot of people super excited
about Canelo Alvarez and triple G which
is next weekend
people are super pumped up about that
fight particularly because we just
passed this Conner
Floyd Mayweather fight Floyd Mayweather
has his way with Conor just puts on a
display and now we're gonna get to see
instead of the master versus a guy who
really wasn't on his level now we're
gonna get to say two guys in their prime
at the top of the food chain two of the
top three top four pound for pound
fighters in the world and they're gonna
go at it so it's good for everybody they
just don't they these guys are so
old-school
they understand social media in a sense
they know they can use it to promote
fights they don't know that it's changed
the whole community and that instead of
like having some stupid rivalry with
this other like sport MMA instead of
having that just accept each other
accept each other and and talk highly of
the best examples in both sports and
everybody will be fine I mean that's how
you're seen with this Conor McGregor
Floyd Mayweather fight that's we're
gonna see with the triple G Canelo
Alvarez fight you don't have to be one
or the other and the boxing people don't
have to not like MMA I love boxing and I
work in MMA I love boxing i watch all
the big fights I'm always gonna it's
fascinating it's awesome it's nice to
know who the real specialists are you
know when it comes to that I love
kickboxing big fan of that too I like to
know I love jiu-jitsu I wanna know wanna
know what how good are the best guys
what would happen the best guy in the
UFC fought the best guy in jiu-jitsu in
a straight-up jiu-jitsu match I want to
see you know those are those things are
interesting
[Applause]
[Music]